l'optimisme qu'incarne la nouvelle
mairesse de montréal a eu des
répercussions jusqu'à l'assemblée
nationale mais la science du montre que
c'est plutôt la négativité qu'elle est
comme si tout allait bien au québec
moi j'veux pas négatif est ambitieux on
nomme d'arrêter d'état ni de commencer à
construire positivement que la science
nous dira pas pour l'année 4 août et
particulièrement en politique les gens
réagissent davantage plus intensément
information formation aussi la réponse
ne sera jamais le négativisme et le
repli en fait c'est que votre cerveau à
mieux le négatif sans que vous le
souhaitiez nécessairement et pourquoi
mais tout simplement parce que notre
cerveau est programmée comme ça tu es
souvent l'hémisphère droit dont celui
impliqué dans les dents le traitement
d'informations négatives exactement
premier d'un cours de l'évolution de
l'espèce tse développer un réflexe de
porter plus spontanément plus rapidement
attention aux stimuli négatif parce que
ce sont des sources potentielles de
danger met un roulant au champ restant
de l'évolution alors comment expliquer
le cas de valérie plante va peut-être
parce que denis coderre incarner quelque
chose de négatif
ça fonctionne chez une certaine pour son
directeur mais chez donc ça entretient
va exacerber un certain cynisme pallier
à ce cynisme le bain le dos rond plutôt
y allier avec un discours positif
c'est une campagne calomnies qui était
une campagne positive
il travaille avec la substance mais fait
avec le sourire ainsi pour mission dans
le paysage politique
reste que la critique la remise en
question c'est un élément fondamental de
la politique est un devoir de nos partis
d'opposition
[Musique]